[Musica]
[Applauso]
una delle definizioni della parola
giudizio
è sentenza pronunciata dal giudice
praticamente una condanna quante volte
ci siamo sentiti giudicati ci siamo
sentiti cucire addosso un'immagine di
noi che non ci appartiene a lungo andare
si rischia di credere a quella immagine
e a forza di sentirselo ripetere il
rischio è quello di costruire un'idea di
noi stessi esattamente come quella
percepita dall'esterno a me è successo
Ho lasciato che la paura del giudizio
mi condannasse mi immobilizzasse
sono nata con una plasia al piede e il
giudizio ha segnato la mia vita l'idea
di essere nata sbagliata diversa
difettata l'avevo fatta mia nonostante
la bambina non fosse nei miei pensieri
successe per osmosi gli sguardi di pena
fissi sulla mia gamba Le parole
denigratorie i bisbigli alle spalle sono
tutte ferite che fanno fatica a
cicatrizzare
e sminuire il problema non funziona
Fregatene di quello che dicono fregatene
se ti guardano non è così semplice Nei
fatti gli sguardi i giudizi sono Lame
affilate che trafiggono il cuore e la
mente e sono capaci anche di far
ammalare
io mi ammalai di depressione per non
sentire più quelle voci mi rinchiusi in
casa nella mia stanza e lì Rimasi per un
anno ogni giorno mi ripromettevo che il
successivo sarebbe stato diverso non
appena sarebbe arrivato il momento
giusto sarei uscita pronta a vivere la
mia vita ma al momento Perfetto non c'è
i cambiamenti avvengono un passo dopo
l'altro è un percorso fatto di salite e
discese è un viaggio
un viaggio Ecco quello che mi serviva
avevo bisogno di allontanare la mia
prospettiva quindi in un giorno
qualunque fece un biglietto di sola
andata per Parigi
nella vita esistono vari punti di vista
e non avevo mai preso in considerazione
quello più importante il mio come ho
detto può capitare di rimanere
intrappolati nelle opinioni esterne come
ti vedono come ti vorrebbero quello che
pensano
come ti trattano influenza la percezione
che abbiamo noi di noi stessi di chi sei
E chi vorresti essere io ho bisogno di
conoscere Chantal andare a scoprire
quale fosse la sua unicità sono sempre
stata appassionata d'arte quindi a
Parigi ho potuto dare libero sfogo a
questa passione ho visitato mostre mi
prendevo Tutto il tempo che volevo per
contemplare un'opera e poi camminavo
camminavo tanto e più scoprivo Parigi e
più scoprivo me stessa avevo anche un
diario nel quale annotavo i miei
pensieri e fu in quel periodo che
iniziai a pensare all'arte e al suo
straordinario potere di aprire elementi
L'arte non deve essere giudicata la sua
definizione non è necessaria l'arte va
sentita con sensibilità e intelligenza e
in qualche modo anche la vita andrebbe
percepita così abbiamo una tela bianca
su cui poter esprimere la propria
individualità la propria unicità liberi
dal giudizio allo spettatore è concesso
osservare l'opera senza però usare
arte in sanscrito significa andare verso
andare oltre e io in quel periodo stavo
andando verso la mia città oltre la
paura del giudizio
prendiamo ad esempio un'opera di Fontana
quei tagli rappresentano la volontà
dell'artista di andare oltre ora
immaginiamo che qualcuno guardando
quest'opera si mette ad improvviso a
ricucirla a strapparla non sarebbe
assurdo questa è la personale visione
dell'artista non deve essere
necessariamente compresa apprezzata né
tantomeno modificata da altri lo stesso
concetto vale per le nostre
individualità chi sei Non Deve
necessariamente essere compreso la tua
visione e la tua libera espressione la
tua vita la tua personale opera d'arte
chitarring una volta disse definire la
mia arte significa distruggere nello
scopo Ecco lasciare che ci mettono delle
etichette pone dei limiti alla
conoscenza di sé
Io non sono nata sbagliata diversa
dittata io sono chi scelgo di essere e
io ho scelto di essere come l'arte
libera da definizioni
al mio rientro in Italia decise di fare
un passo fondamentale forse quello più
importante prendermi cura di me dei miei
valori del mio corpo quindi iniziai a
curare la mia depressione ripresi i miei
studi in moda iniziare a lavorare anche
come modella e inizia a praticare uno
sport che mi era sempre piaciuto ma non
avevo mai avuto il coraggio di provare
il surf
e lo step successivo fu quello di
indossare pantaloncini per la prima
volta in pubblico lo fece durante un
servizio fotografico che avevo a Milano
volevo che fosse un momento importante
Volevo che segnasse un nuovo inizio
quello di non nascondermi più
volevo che fosse speciale quindi
contattai un mio carissimo amico artista
Francesco e le chiesi se se la sentiva
di decorare la mia gamba e lui mi
rispose Non l'ho mai fatto ma ci
proviamo quello era lo spirito giusto
quindi l'idea di un mulboard uno stile e
lui creò la sua opera sulla mia protesi
con quella protesi decorata a foglie
d'oro muovevo i miei passi e le persone
si avvicinavano a me con un sorriso
chiedendomi cosa fosse che disegno era
se potevano vederlo più da vicino e
Quella fu la prova che avevo ragione che
l'arte avvicina le persone apre elementi
e dona punti di vista nuovi sulle cose
può piacere o non piacere non importa
finché prevale la libertà di esprimere
se stessi
decise di realizzare anche un altro
desiderio quello di aprire
un'associazione per dare punti di vista
nuovi quindi nel 2019 ho aperto gli uni
KS un'associazione no profit con sede a
Pisa che vuole sensibilizzare su
disabilità e diversità attraverso l'arte
a 360 gradi e poi dal provarlo a farlo
con determinazione ho l'onore di essere
dal 2019 in nazionale italiana di surf
paralimpico
ricorda ancora quando ho imparato
l'importanza delle sfumature avrà avuto
sugli 11 e 12 anni mio nonno che
dipingeva per hobby un giorno mi disse
che mi avrebbe insegnato ad usare gli
acquerelli quindi prese una tela e si
mise a disegnare e mi chiese di che
colore è il mare Guarda bene perché ha
mille sfumature Qui c'è del giallo Qui
del verde e intanto l'albero riflesso
nell'acqua che stava disegnando stava
prendendo forma poi preso un colore che
non c'entrava niente con i colori della
realtà di un paesaggio e passò una
pennellata decisa sulla tela Io rimasi
in silenzio a pensare che era un peccato
aver rovinato un disegno che stava
venendo così bene ma lui mi guarda mi
chiese Cosa succede se sbagli se sbagli
continui a dipingere asciughi un po' qui
passi un po' di colore di qua e poi in
realtà Guarda che bella sfumatura è
venuta
Ecco la vita è la nostra opera d'arte in
divenire non importa se non abbiamo
riconosciuto subito il nostro valore se
abbiamo dato retta che ci voleva vedere
sbagliati difettati colpevoli si può
cadere perderci cambiare Fa tutto parte
della creazione di noi e quello che
pensavamo fosse un difetto uno sbaglio
scopriremo essere la sfumatura Senza la
quale quell'opera non sarebbe stata così
incredibilmente bella
[Applauso]
proviamo
a guardare le cose con nuove prospettive
con sensibilità
passione e mente aperta
Proviamo a guardare noi stessi e gli
altri
con sensibilità amore privi di giudizio
e definizione proviamoci
siamo tutti artisti
La nostra vita è arte e ognuno di noi è
un capolavoro Grazie
[Applauso]